what are the attributes of the most
powerful brands brands are really about
bringing a rational and emotional
connection because the best brands have
a personal engagement and the best
brands and the brands that are really
long-term are those brands that in fact
have what I call a higher purpose that
it's more than just selling a product
that you're changing people's lives
you're impacting people's lives you're
allowing people to have fun and when you
have a brand that combines that rational
value proposition with a emotional
connection it's really powerful what
people forget because the card has been
so successful is the company started off
as a freight forwarding company and
what's critical is the reinvention of
the company over 163 years
one was that commitment to service was
really critical the point I make about
our travels check business is that it
had no income requirement anyone could
get it it was used all over the world
that helped build the brand allowing us
to offer a card right now part of what I
do particularly with the partnerships
that we have with a number of digital
companies I say the form factor is
irrelevant
the reality is think about the card as a
platform to deliver service so what's
important is that you've got to
understand to create a brand you need a
core mission and for us we want to be
the most respected service brand trust
of the brand is very critical service is
very critical security is very critical
and then what you've got to do is
constant
innovate because if you want to be a
leading brand
you've got to innovate in the
marketplace all the time and what I
would also emphasize with respect to
service is what I found is and I say
this publicly and certainly I'm very
competitive I want to win so I don't
foolishly give out secrets but the
reality is that most companies don't
want to make a commitment to service one
is because it's a long-term investment
two is they don't have the right metrics
in place to know they're getting the
returns we in fact know what service
interactions will generate levels of
spending we know what will drive
retention and loyalty of our customers
and one of the things that we did in our
service despite the fact that for years
we had great service around ten years
ago we said we're gonna revamp it we're
gonna reinvent the way we do service we
think people are too robotic we think it
were to rule focused and we want to
empower the people who are serving our
customers where that's online or offline
and we literally changed fundamental
aspects of our service and that leads to
a very important point which I believe
in strongly is you always want to create
the company that will put yourself out
of business that's the way you
constantly need to think and if you
believe that you're successful and you
get arrogant about that success that
success becomes a rut
you